hi I'm Francisco or Frankie and I'm also
princess or Frank and today we're gonna
be playing rock-paper-scissors loser
gets their haircuts hopefully it's good
[Music]
we met through some apps I'm not gonna
say which one and I started to like gas
him up on his comments like in this
picture also we had a lot of things in
common so we DM each other about music
and stuff that's kind of like our
comment very true
and so we've been together for about
nine months he always gets a kid like
all the time so it's very I'm like it's
okay right now I'm like a two week three
week you just got a cut though yeah I
did I change it all the time yeah did I
get her cat the different places but
it's never too different he wants me to
grow my hair out so I did try to grow my
hair out for a little bit you can go
like a few weeks Lanie it's like a
little shaggy but when you get to cut he
looks I'm excited rock paper scissors
[Music]
thank you so nice to meet you I'm gonna
be doing here today I brought some inspo
okay oh the heavy layers I think we
should go with the shaved for surfers
okay I do kind of like this like Lions
idea yeah like do two stripes just right
yes yes I don't think you'll like the
lines because he doesn't like to be like
too out there let's do it yeah all right
Frankie how are you feeling today a
little nervous yeah I'm excited he was
talking about like hair designs the
hustling on me like on my head so that's
probably gonna be something like that
shaving my head I don't think would be a
thing but it'd be kind of freaky I
shaved my head you might have something
of this see so there's no mirrors
involved you're actually gonna be the
last person to see your haircut okay
yeah lovely all right let's get started
let's do it
I don't wanna thank you like he is a
free spirit wild card is what I used to
describe them right here so he's just
full of energy full of life sometimes
I'm like bro where do you get all his
energy from I left him for who he is
he's really free and like accepting of
other people but then I think you guys
are in sync
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm excited I'm gonna left for a miscue
that's what he wanted it's good I won
you always want to do this oh my god I
can live with it I mean it's not there I
mean look at it like like oh my god oh
my god he's gonna do this uline's to me
neck hoarsely no I'm coming back to the
revenge video Oh
[Laughter]
[Music]